Guten Morgen Linus.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Folge zweihundertachtundachtzig vom siebenundzwanzigsten.
Februar zweitausendneunzehn, endlich mal ohne Tim. Ja, wir können endlich mal Logbuch so machen, wie wir das für richtig halten und haben direkt mal das äh Intro äh uns von jemand anderem beisteuern lassen, nämlich von der.
Trickfilmsektion der hedonistischen Internationale, die ein äh Remix gemacht hat von unserem Intro letzte Woche, hast du das gesehen, Thomas.
Das habe ich gesehen, ja. Es ist äh schön, also wir müssen jetzt alle Memes nochmal auskosten, bevor sie weg sind.
Genau, solange es noch geht, ne, konnten wir noch einen kleinen Hitler Reacts äh mit einstreuen. Gesehen frage ich auch deshalb, weil wir äh wir haben ja tatsächlich das war auch ein bisschen anstrengend. Ähm.
Wenn man sowas mit Tim macht, dann kann man das ja nicht einfach machen, sondern das muss dann natürlich erstmal hier das das Studio äh komplett gefeintunt werden und das muss dann auch vom Timing so stimmen.
Ich tatsächlich am Ende das einfach das YouTube-Video drunter legen konnte und das tatsächlich gepasst hat. Also der, wir haben quasi Lippensynchron zu dem Video gesprochen.
Und ich habe das dann auch tatsächlich nochmal als Video.
Hochgeladen und verbreitet und es funktionierte quasi mit mit minimalen Anpassungen fast Lippensynchron.
Ja, die Mieterebene entdeckt ganz neue Dimensionen an Produktionsmöglichkeiten. Äh ich finde das gut. So, so macht Tim auch nochmal YouTube.
So kriegen wir den Tim auch noch in YouTube reingezerrt. YouTube spielt ja jetzt auch bei unserem, wir wollen heute eine relativ monothematische Sendung machen. Es wird.
Einzig und allein um die Möglichkeiten gehen, jetzt noch das Internet zu retten, denn was ist.
Passiert, wir haben's in der letzten Woche schon äh darüber gesprochen der äh die finale Text steht fest, das Trilogergebnis ist gestern am sechsundzwanzigsten Februar im Rechtsausschuss.
Entschieden worden, nochmal bestätigt worden, ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, wie oft da irgendetwas entschieden wird, ne. Was war's jetzt genau? Diesmal wurde in vom Ausschuss entschieden.
Also es ist so, dass äh jetzt, wo der der Trilog sich geeinigt hat, also dieses äh eigentlich äh Geheime in den EU-Verträgen gar nicht vorgesehene Gremium, wo Parlament äh Rate so mitge
Mitgliedsstaaten und Kommissionen über den fertigen Text verhandeln. Das haben wir ja schon
Das ist der denkbar schlechteste Text von allen Versionen, die wir je gesehen haben. Der Rat hat das angenommen. Da gab es ja irgendwie die berühmte Einigung zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich. Aufgrund des äh Anrufs von
bei Mer
Da ist die SPD auch umgefallen und ja, nun ist äh das Ganze nur noch beim Parlament anhängig und da ist es einfach so, es muss zuerst durch den Ausschuss durch, in dem Fall den Rechtsausschuss, der ist federführend und der hat gestern eben
abgestimmt und natürlich das Ganze durchgefunken im Rechtsausschuss ähm haben wir keine guten Karten. Ähm wir wissen jetzt aber auch wer, dort wie abgestimmt hat.
Genau, wir nennen Namen, es reicht. Wir nennen Namen. Wer hat im Rechtsausschuss dafür gestimmt? Die erste Name ist überhaupt keine Überraschung, ne.
Nee, Axel Voss.
Immer noch nicht der unbelehrbare Axel-Fuss.
Bäcker, österreichischer ähm konservativer von der Volkspartei auch absolut keine Überraschung. Ähm, mit den Menschen muss man auch gar nicht wirklich lange diskutieren, der ist sehr ähm auf der Linie der Urheberrechtsindustrie.
Dann haben wir Swobotter, Lamazur, Labrillour, Diedler, Radlef, das ist die Volkspartei von.
Oder Radef.
Radef, Radef, ja.
Danke. Ähm auch bei äh also die Sozialdemokraten Hannibal Rosé und Gaspara von den liberalen Kabara, der war auch Schattenberichterstatter, äh Pin und Pinto,
äh ICA, also Toris, Karim, äh Monau von der EFD.
Was ist EFB.
Auf Europa der Freiheit und Demokratie.
Eine, der ihr im rechten Spektrum angesiedelten Gruppen äh aber nicht ganz rechts rechts, aber nagel mich nicht drauf fest. Ähm und dann haben wir noch äh Boutournee und Leberaton.
Ich entschuldige mich bei allen Nationen, deren Aussprache ich gerade.
Also bei den französischen ähm und dagegen haben gestimmt von der EP niemand, ne? Von der Koalition von der Koalition EP, aber von den progressiven schon.
Das sind die Sozialdemokraten. Hier ist äh Timo Wöl.
Das ist das sollte man auch immer nochmal dazu sagen. Dass die besonders progressiv werden, aber wie das immer so ist, ne? Christ äh Christ, demokratischer Christ sozial progressiv, das sind ja immer nur ähm das ist ja immer nur Schall und Rauch,
Aber immerhin sind die progressiven so progressiv, dass sie gespalten sind, ne.
Ja, das das äh ist auch sicherlich ähm
eine Diaspaltinien, auf die wir uns fokussieren sollten bei den Sozialdemokraten gibt's noch keine geschlossene Meinung dazu und da kann man sicherlich auch noch den meisten Boden gewinnen. Aber auf jeden Fall auf unserer Seite waren äh Wölken
der sich auch auf Twitter sehr bemüht um dieses Dossier zeigt und äh den dem kann man folgen, der ist sehr lustig. Ähm äh.
Ist ja so lustig wie dieser andere äh wie heißt der Schulze oder was?
Der den Vogel da abgeschossen hat, das haben wir in der letzten Sendung vergessen. Dieser, dieser Typ, der ähm Beschwerde-E-Mails bekommen hat
festgestellt hat, dass viele davon bei G-Mail gehostet sind und sich dann zu der Theorie hin hinreißen lassen hat, dass Google jetzt E-Mails an ihn fälscht.
Der Typ ist der hat den einer abgeholt oder.
Hart getwittert am fünfzehnten Februar Sven Schulze. Jetzt kommen wieder sekündlich Mails zum Thema Uploadfilter und Artikel dreizehn rein. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass diese inhaltlich nicht richtig sind, stammen
alle von Konten. Mensch, Google, ich weiß doch, dass ihr sauer seid, ab, da habt ihr diesen, diese Fake-Aktion wirklich nötig. Ähm
und er hat da, ich muss kurz nachschauen, ja, vierhundertsiebzig Retweets bekommen und einen sehr, sehr, sehr langen
Also er hat's damit wirklich zum der ähm Leute geschafft, die äh diesen Artikel dreizehn ablehnen und auch sehr schön zum Ausdruck gebracht. Ähm dass Politiker, die dieses Internet wirklich nicht verstanden haben, ihre Gesetze darüber machen.
Ja, die hat doch wirklich die Pfanne heiß. Also das kannst du nicht mehr ernst nehmen.
Das ist doch wirklich also überhaupt die Idee, ja? Also die die Idee, dass dass Google jetzt eine Fake-Aktion macht.
Das ist doch wirklich also ganz ehrlich.
Das doch nun wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr weit hergeholt, sowas würde ich jetzt von irgendwie von so einem After äh erwarten, ja, aber doch nicht von einem.
Herr schalten wir da mal ein, also es ist ja auch äh recht viel passiert.
Noch erst ganz kurz, äh, weil ich die da reingerät spiele, wir müssen einmal noch die die Namen zu Ende nenn.
Genau, also auf der guten Seite stehen äh Wolken, Gepard und Geringer von den Sozialdemokraten, von den Grünen, Reda
Juliareder, Anderson und Hautala, äh Slotowisky äh von EFD, Adolfini und Spinelli von der Gur, also die Linke in Deutschland.
Ich glaube, du hast zwei Namen falsch ausgesprochen. Das ist nicht Adolfini, sondern Adinolfi.
Tut mir leid, ich bin ein Österreicher.
Und es ist Lotowski, aber Aluphili.
Okay. Oh mein Gott. Jetzt haben wir sie verloren. Äh.
Adinolfi, ja? Und ähm die auch immer natürlich überraschend äh Julia Reder von den Grünen, ne? Würde man jetzt im meinen wieso? Der ist nicht von Grün ist doch eine Piraten ähm die Fraktion.
Im äh europäischen Parlament sind ja immer so ein bisschen anders sortiert.
Genau, die fassen sich einfach zusammen zu Parteienfamilien auf europäischer Ebene und
da wird dann eben auch nochmal ähm geschachert, da geht's auch um äh einfach äh eine ideologische Beheimatung, ja, mit welchen Leuten will man gemeinsam an den Themen arbeiten, sich Büros teilen und solche Sachen.
Unten und neben wem willst du sitzen in der Klasse, ne?
Genau, genau. Ähm weil wenn du bei keiner Parteienfamilie bist, bist du bei den und das sind die, die wirklich auch keiner haben wollte. Also, ähm.
Das sind, das sind äh.
Tatsächlich so also die die NP.
Sonneborn und die Faschisten, ne?
Ja, mehr oder weniger.
Okay.
Wir haben jetzt also im Rechtsausschuss verloren. Ähm deswegen ist es wichtig jetzt mal
sich den Status anzuschauen. Wo stehen wir und wo steht vor allem noch die Debatte? Ähm wir haben
massiver Angriffe äh auf auf den Protest und die Ablehnung von Artikel dreizehn. Ähm
hier wird eine ganze junge Generation an Europäerinnen und Europäern plakativ als Spots bezeichnet. Man geht überhaupt nicht auf die inhaltliche Krit,
dieser Menschen ein, die da wirklich berechtigte Sorge um ihre Lebensrealit,
um um ihren Medienkonsum, um Informationsverhalten und ihre Informationsfreiheit haben. Ähm und was macht die EU-Kommission? Sie veröffentlicht noch Mediumartikel vom offiziellen Kommissionsaccount, wo sie
Diese ganze Generation als Mob
bezeichnet, wo sie diesen Menschen, die sie wirklich zum ersten Mal politisch engagieren, noch dazu auf EU-Ebene, die einfach plakativ wegwischt, also da unabhängig vom eigentlichen Thema, was da für ein
demokratischer, kollateralschaden in Kauf genommen wird. Das ist enorm.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich, ne? Also dass diese
Was was da denn Menschen vermittelt wird, die sich da jetzt wirklich wie du gerade sagst zum ersten Mal politisch engagieren und dann fährst du den von Kopf mit, du bist irgendwie eine Fake-Aktion von Gmail oder du bist ein Bot oder du, du wurdest
betrogen oder du bist du bist doof, ja. Unglaublich. Also das ist einer Demokratie dermaßen.
Unwürdig und so ähm
so übel, ja? Ähm ich finde das übrigens, das habe ich ja auch regelmäßig gesagt, ich das gleiche gilt für solche Sachen wie ähm
überhaupt 'ne Diskussion zu führen ja Social Bots verändern den den politischen Willen und manipulieren die Leute in in falsche Meinungen ne? Das sind auch so so so Strange
Argumentationen wie ich finde, die halt auch eine eine sehr üble Geringschätzung der.
Der Menschen widerspiegeln. Übrigens auch, wenn die.
Wenn die doofe Entscheidungen treffen, ja, was weiß ich, Brexit oder sonst was, die haben eben immer noch äh sind jetzt keine Bots und irgendwelche Meinungsmaschinen und die haben auch irgendwie ihre Quellen aus, aus denen die äh ihre Inhalte beziehen. Und ich finde es halt ähm.
Auch sehr auf eine Weise sehr dumm ähm diese Menschen so auf diese Weise abzustempeln, ja? Äh.
Ja und äh.
Oder den politischen Gegner auf diese Weise abzustempeln, weil das das heißt hier gibt es keine Kommunikation zwischen.
Hier gibt's gar nichts, hier gibt's kein Angebot, hier gibt's gar nichts zwischen uns mehr.
Das Problem ist ja noch dazu, ähm äh indem man so plakativ nur antwortet auf diese Kritik ähm äh verhindert man ja auch, dass es irgendwie zu einer Lösung oder zum Konsens kommen kann. Und äh dass du
gegenseitig ja strategisch. Äh die wissen, dass sie gegen eine Front von,
über den UN-Sonderberichterstatter für Meinungsfreiheit bis zu einer ganzen Generation von Jugendlichen recht wenig Gegenargumente haben, ja. Eigentlich wenn man da äh äh neutral drauf,
würde als Sachpolitiker nicht als Politiker, der von Axel Springer,
gesagt bekommt. Das ist wichtig und so machen wir das. Dann glaube ich, wäre diese Abstimmung sehr schnell sehr eindeutig. Ähm aber das ganze Ding ist immer noch ernst
gemeint und es äh gibt jetzt eben auch schon einen Abstimmungstermin für das Plenum des Europaparlaments. Ähm der ist am siebenundzwanzigsten März, also genau
ein Monat von heute und das heißt wir haben noch genau einen Monat um das Ganze zu verhindern.
Wenn wir das nicht schaffen, ist es gültiges Gesetz. Und es gibt dann so Leute, die sagen, ja, aber das ist doch sicherlich ganz klar, grundrechtswidrig und dagegen kann man doch klagen, ja
kann man machen. Das ist aber eine Richtlinie. Und ihr erinnert euch vielleicht äh äh wie das mit
Diese anderen Richtlinie war zu Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ja
die ist auch beschlossen worden und dann hat äh man Jahre gewartet, wir haben Jahre gebraucht bis wir das Ding vom europäischen Gerichtshof weggeklagt haben und es gibt heute immer noch in der Hälfte aller EU-Länder solche Gesetze zu Vorratsdatenspeicherung
weil die Richtlinie ein nationales Gesetz überführt wird und wenn ihr die Richtlinie aufhebst, bleiben die nationalen Gesetze übrig. Das heißt, das hier in der Grundsatzentscheidung.
Die kriegen wir so schnell nicht mehr weg. Und die wird massive Konsequenzen haben, ähm was die Vielfalt der Inhalte im Internet angeht.
Was die Möglichkeit sich auch kritisch über Dritte zu äußern, Dinge zu remixen, zu zitieren, zu parodieren, betrifft
und wir werden in einem anderen dunkleren, tristeren Internet aufwachen, wenn dieses Gesetz so durchgeht. Und,
man man darf leider auch nicht glauben, dass ähm es beim Urheberrecht bleiben wird. Ähm wir haben schon gesehen, äh
Terrorverordnung, Uploadfilter für extremistische Inhalte. Es wird nächstes Jahr äh nächste Legislaturperiode in der EU, eine riesige Reform. Ähm der E-Commerce-Richtlinie geben, also von allen Fragen der Plattformregulierung
da werden auch, wenn wir jetzt hier diesen Kampf verlieren, haben wir vielleicht Upload-Filter wegen Fake News. Also es wird wirklich an der an der grundlegenden Architektur des Internets hier etwas entschieden,
dass wir so schnell nicht mehr wegbekommen. Und uns bleibt nur noch genau dieses eine Monat das zu verhindern.
Jetzt muss man da natürlich noch ein bisschen zusagen in dieser ganzen Debatte um Uploadfilter wurde schon sehr häufig
gesagt, jetzt kommt die entscheidende Abstimmung, ne? Die entscheidende Abstimmung im EU-Parlament, die entscheidende Abstimmung im Trilog, die entscheidende Abstimmung. Ähm das ist jetzt wirklich
die letzte, ne? Das ist also das ist jetzt wirklich dieser Prozess natürlich auf ähm äh ja schon
ähm sehr, sehr beschwerlich und ähm.
Schwierig, da die Motivation aufrechtzuerhalten, weil's im Prinzip so ist so, ja hier, wir haben äh Moment gegen Up gegen Upload-Filter haben wir doch letzte Woche schon irgendwie Vollgas gegeben. Jetzt müssen wir auf einmal nochmal gegen gegen Uploadfilter Vollgas geben. Ja, müssen wir
so so ist es tatsächlich. Ähm, dieser Prozess ist langsam und eigentlich würde man ja oder hat viele Stufen, eigentlich würde man ja erwarten, dass da wenigstens jeder einzelne dieser Stufen.
Einen Hebel bietet das Resort ähm Einzug erhält, aber stattdessen äh irgendwie leider nicht.
Du kannst auf jeder dieser Stufen hätte, hätte man sich dazu entscheiden können, das ganze Ding zu töten und einfach äh Recection äh also sozusagen
das hätte man tun können, aber ähm jetzt sind wir halt wirklich so fünf vor zwölf. Also wenn diese Abstimmung, die am siebenundzwanzigsten dritten ist, äh, schiefgeht
dann wird das Ding im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht und gilt. Da da kommt keine Chance mehr, das dann noch zu verhindern.
Okay und was machen wir jetzt in exakt diesem Monat? Das soll auch heute Fokus unserer Sendung sein, einen Monat Zeit am siebenundzwanzigsten bis zum siebenundzwanzigsten dritten.
Irgendwie das Ruder herumzureißen. Welche Aktion gi.
Also, die ähm allererste, die man immer machen kann, ist auf die Straße gehen. Es gibt Demos. Ja, ich glaube, die Berliner sind als nächstes dran. Kannst du dazu was sagen.
Ja, zweiter dritter äh ja doch zweiter dritter, genau, das ist der Samstag dieses Wochenende, ja, Februar ist ja ein kurzer Monat. Ähm.
Findet die Auftaktdemo für Berlin statt. Das ist nicht die Auftaktdemo überhaupt. Es gab ja, ich glaube die erste war in,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja, die war ganz spontan, ja.
Ne, das waren irgendwie, was waren das? Tausend Leute, spontan in Görm. Jetzt sind wir mal gespannt, wie viel in Berlin am Samstag passiert. Wir haben's in der letzten Sendung ja auch schon äh angekündigt, dreizehn Uhr,
Springer Hochhaus.
Es los und der Große, der große Tag, wo eben auch Berlin äh mitmachen wird, ist dann eben der dreiundzwanzigste, vier Tage davor. Da soll ja, ist ja quasi der europaweite große Akt.
Genau, da kann man sich informieren auf Safe
D-Internet Punkt Info Slash Demos. Dort findet man auch in anderen deutschen Städten, in Polen, in äh Niederlanden, Belgien, äh Demonstrationen, wenn dann neue dazukommen, werden die dort eingetragen
wenn ihr eure Stadt dort nicht seht und ihr habt sind Freunde oder auch nur fünf
meldet die Demo an, es werden mehr kommen und äh dann ist es sehr wichtig, dass man auch zeigt, dass das irgendwie in ganz Europa ist
und der dreiundzwanzigste ist als Aktionstag ausgerufen, das hat sich jetzt eh als gutes Datum bewiesen.
Da gibt's übrigens auch einen sehr schönen Artikel bei Netzpolitik Dot Org, den wir dann nochmal in die Shownote
in die Show Notes aufnehmen, wo gesagt wird, so deine erste Demo, ja? Was musst du machen
Ähm ne, was sind irgendwie die Schritte, wie funktioniert das, diese diese Demo ähm anzumelden, ne? Du musst irgendwie ähm,
dir überlegen, wie das irgendwie funktioniert, ne? Machen, verbinde dich mit anderen, schreibe einen Aufruf, melde die Versammlung an, ne, was bedeutet das, da gibt's dann unter Umständen das Anmelderge
mit der Polizei, wo dann muss das irgendwie bewerben, Facebook, Seite, Webseite und so weiter. Pressebescheid sagen
Demoschilder malen, damit das schön bunt ist, weil die ne, dass man den Leuten auch bisschen Demo also Service bieten kann.
Lautsprecheranlage organisieren, Redebeiträge organisieren ähm und wie man von auf der Demo kommuniziert, sehr schön. Ähm und ich fand das in dem, eine Einleitung gab's so einen wunderschönen.
Äh Begriff. Für eines der schönsten demokratisch,
Erlebnisse die erste eigene Demo, den fand ich äh fand ich sehr schön den Artikel mal zu lesen und dann noch in die Tat umzusetzen, wenn eure Stadt auf der Liste fehlt, ähm setzt sie drauf.
Nehmt das in die Hand, denn wie das leider so ist, das lässt sich irgendwie jetzt ganz offensichtlich nicht mehr klären durch, wo muss ich spenden.
Wo muss ich klicken? Sondern da geht's jetzt wirklich darum zu zeigen.
Habe hier eine politische Position, die möchte ich gerne, dass die berücksichtigt wird. Und ich werde mir das irgendwie merken, wenn das nicht getan wird.
Ähm womit wir bei den weiteren Aktionen werden. Also Demonstrationen haben wir.
Genau, dann gibt's noch eine Petition. Äh auf Change dot org, die hat inzwischen äh kurz vor der N Sendung so ungefähr vier Komma acht neun Millionen Unterschriften
Das ist jetzt schon die größte Petition Europas und ist,
dir Wachstumsrate auf dem Weg zur größten Position weltweit zu werden. Ähm also sollte man vielleicht nicht ignorieren, äh das Ding, wenn ihr es noch nicht unterschrieben habt, wir verlinken es, unterschreibt es, wenn ihr's schon unterschrieben habt,
teilt es, teilt es auf allen euren Kanälen, mit Leuten, ähm nutzt das vielleicht auch gleich als Gelegenheit, um ähm
zu informieren und aufzuklären über ähm Uploadfilter. Das ist auch nochmal irgendwie so eine ganz, ganz kleine Sache, die man machen kann äh die aber eben auch dazu führt, dass die äh Zahl vielleicht noch über die fünf Millionen drüber geht
vor der Abstimmung. Ähm dann gibt es noch was, dass man tun kann. Ähm save your Internet Punkt EU ist eine ähm.
Koalition von NGOs, die haben schon über längere Zeit Kampagne gemacht und dort kann man immer noch E-Mails schreiben. Äh E-Mails an die eigenen Abgeordneten
das wird einem dort einfach gemacht. Es ist aber trotzdem gut, wenn man selber einen Text schreibt. Das große Problem bei
E-Mails haben wir ja vorher schon gehört von Sven Schulze, dass der nicht mehr ernst genommen werden, dass man das einfach als Bot abtut. Genauso bei,
oder Facebook Kommentaren. Ähm, da hat man leider das Problem, dass äh dieses Totschlagargument des Spots genommen wird. Ähm auch wenn ich das nicht ernst
nehme und das eigentlich auch für ähm eine illegitime Art von ich will mich damit nicht beschäftigen
ähm ist es halt draußen in der Welt und es ist ähm textbasierte Kommunikation leider nicht der effizienteste Weg, um in die Aufmerksamkeit von Abgeordneten im Europaparlament zu kommen. Wachse gehen ja auch nicht mehr
die die kommen inzwischen im Outlook an, nachdem wir das damals bei Safety Internet und Netzautalit.
Genutzt haben, haben die reagiert und äh heute kommen die leider nicht mehr physisch ausgedruckt ins Büro an, sondern äh werden elektronisch ähm.
Eingesammelt und auch ausgefiltert. Ähm ja
Und das ist eigentlich eine recht triste Situation, deswegen haben wir noch was Neues vorbereitet. Ähm es gibt seit
Montag, also jetzt ist der dritte Tag, eine neue Kampagnen-Webseite, die ähm die letzten eineinhalb Monate äh geschraubt hat und die heißt Ninetin dot you.
Wir haben dort ähm einen neuen Weg gewählt. Wir haben ähm.
Es möglich gemacht, ganz einfach gratis mit den Abgeordneten per Telefon zu sprechen. Und dieser Anruf in.
Demonstration, Petition, Telefon.
Genau. Das ist eigentlich, das ist, das ist eine gute Reihenfolge. Ähm äh wobei die Demos, da kann man sich drauf vorbereiten, ja. Also das Anrufen hat äh folgenden Hintergrund ähm wenn.
Abgeordnete im Europaparlament wirklich eure Stimme hören. Wenn die merken, das ist ein echter Mensch, der besorgt ist zu einem Thema. Dann hat das den allergrößten Impact
ja
Ähm es gibt auch in den Büros von den Abgeordneten, die wir vorher gerade genannt haben, weil sie für Artikel dreizehn gestimmt haben. Da gibt es auch Menschen, die ans Telefon gehen. Das sind die Assistenten dieser Abgeordneten. Und wenn ihr denen ins Gewissen redet.
Natürlich auf 'ne freundliche Art und Weise und auf 'ne höfliche Art, das ist ganz wichtig dann habt ihr damit den allergrößten Effekt.
Also ein Telefonanruf ähm ersetzt locker tausend E-Mails.
Und ein Telefonanruf, die dir vielleicht einmal pro Woche macht oder.
Zweimal die Woche, das könnt ihr euch auf der Webseite so einrichten, dass ihr immer in der, weiß nicht, um dreizehn Uhr angerufen werdet oder ähm gleich um neun Uhr in der Früh,
und dann spendet ihr diese fünf Minuten an diesem Tag. Dort mit einem Abgeordneten zu sprechen. Das ist der größte Effekt, den ihr.
Gegen Uploadfilter noch haben könnt.
Und die Website ist dafür da, dass du einfach wie möglich zu machen. Wer noch nicht weiß, was so die Argumente sind, wir haben auch ein Animationsvideo von dem wunderbaren Alexander Lehmann produzieren lassen, indem wir
Upload-Filter nochmal erklären, ähm was ist das Problem damit, was wie genau funktioniert das? Dieses Video eignet sich auch sehr gut ums vielleicht ähm
im erweiterten Umkreis zu teilen, in der Familie äh bei Leuten, die noch nicht verstanden haben, wo das Problem ist.
Und äh insgesamt soll's äh eben so einfach wie möglich sein, hier mitzumachen. Ähm der Name dieser Webseite,
äh hinten schon da drauf. Platt steht ja für Wahlversprechen im Englischen. Ähm und wir wollen, dass Abgeordneten wirklich,
unterschreiben gegen Artikel dreizehn, gegen Uploadfilter zu stimmen. Ähm aktuell äh jetzt in den ersten drei Tagen haben das schon.
Äh vierundfünfzig Abgeordnete getan.
Warum sollen sie den unterscheiden.
Weil wir dann sehen, dass wir uns schon Schritt und Schritt deiner Mehrheit nähern. Also wir wollen einfach jetzt schon die die Zahl, die wir brauchen ist am Ende,
eben die Hälfte der siebenhunderteinundfünfzig Abgeordneten im Europaparlament, die sich gegen Artikel dreizehn gegen das Trilogmandat aussprechen.
Und um dieser Zahl näher zu kommen bieten wir den Abgeordneten eben die Möglichkeit an diesen Pleps zu unterschreiben
und sich damit dann auch zu binden, weil ich kann ja am Telefon leicht versprechen, ja, ja, ich bin dagegen und in Wirklichkeit bin ich's nicht. Also wir listen hier natürlich auch die Abgeordneten mit ihrem finalen Abstimmungsverhältnis
Ähm weil äh das Schöne ist an dieser Stelle, dass es ein Wahlversprechen, dass sie uns abgeben und dass sie noch vor der Wahl einlösen müssen. Im Mai
wird in ganz Europa gewählt.
Genau und dann kommt unser Versprechen zum Zuge, das nämlich hier sehr groß auf der Seite steht. Wir wählen nur Leute,
die Gegenartikel dreizehn gestimmt haben
Und das ist natürlich denke ich ein sehr wichtiger Faktor für dieses, für dieses Wahlversprechen, was vor der Wahl eingelöst werden kann und wo man sich auch nachher nicht wundern muss, ja? Also diese vierundfünfzig Politikerinnen und Politiker.
Die haben jetzt gesagt, okay, ich werde das tun.
So, das ist jetzt erstmal ein Wahlversprechen, insofern, also das ist ein Versprechen. Da kann man jetzt erstmal sehen, ob sie's halten. Und diejenigen, die das nicht,
die sich da nicht angeschlossen haben oder deren Abstimmungsverhalten uns am sagen wir mal siebenundzwanzigsten dritten nicht gefällt.
Dieses Verhalten haben wir im, wann ist es genau? Am sechsundzwanzigsten Mai natürlich noch nicht vergessen, ne?
Das ist ja gerade mal zwei Monate später ähm ein Monat äh zwei Monate minus einen Tag später ist die Europawahl und da können wir natürlich alle nochmal auf Platsch zwanzig neunzehn EU schauen.
Wie haben die Leute denn abgestimmt bei den Upload-Filtern? Da würde ich mich aber nochmal orientieren.
Und ich denke, da kann man jetzt schon mal sagen, fünf äh gute fünf Millionen äh Stimmen sind im.
Sack, ja, sind in der Tombola, die sich im Zweifelsfall an Pletsch zwanzig neunzehn orientieren werden und sagen, nee, pass mal auf. Äh Freundchen Schulze, Freundchen, Voss. Das habe ich mir jetzt lange genug angeschaut.
Das wird so nicht gewählt. Das haben wir so nicht bestellt, ne? Da geben wir die Stimme jemand anders, der ähm,
oder die hier äh mein meine Wünsche umsetzt und nicht irgendwie bei mir in die in die Kandare fährt und mir mein YouTube kaputt macht. Und das finde ich einen sehr schönen Ansatz, den ihr da fahr.
Also wir versuchen die Wahl zu unserem Vorteil zu nutzen, ähm das äh hat schon in der Vergangenheit gut funktioniert bei Acta,
und bei der Abstimmung zu Netzzeutralität in erster Lesung haben wir es auch geschafft, äh ein sehr gutes Ergebnis zu erzielen, weil wir ganz nah an der Europawahl waren. Und äh da sind wir jetzt hier auch
genau dieses Momentum müssen wir jetzt nutzen
und äh zu so groß wie jetzt hier irgendwie die Anrufflut ist, umso bewusster ist das den Abgeordneten auch schon im Vorhinein. Ähm.
Die ganze Webseite äh ist jetzt schon auf zehn Sprachen übersetzt, äh Englisch, Deutsch, Griechisch, Spanisch, Italienisch, Polnisch, Portugiesisch, Slowenisch, Schwedisch und Katalanisch. Und da kommt
kommen heute vielleicht noch irgendwie bulgarisch dazu. Also äh wir schauen, dass diese Kampagne auch wirklich europaweit.
Ähm aufgenommen wird. Das äh lässt sich nicht allein in Deutschland und Österreich lösen. Das ist ein europäisches Thema. Wir haben auch fünfzehn
NGOs aus zwölf Ländern dabei
inklusive Etri natürlich und Open Norlege international und aus vielen anderen Ländern auch. Auch der CCC und die digitale Gesellschaft sind mit dabei
Und ja, es ist halt wirklich der Versuch so einen, einen Ruck jetzt nochmal durch ganz Europa gehen zu lassen und in wirklich in vielen Ländern, in vielen Sprachen gleichzei,
ähm das zu kommunizieren.
Und äh deswegen ist es ganz wichtig, dass ihr jetzt vor dieser Website gehört habt, die vielleicht teilt mit euren Freunden, aber ganz wichtig ist, selber auch wirklich anzurufen.
Wenn man irgendwie erst äh jetzt am Abend diesen Podcast hörst und dann sagt man, okay, gut. Äh da ist jetzt keiner mehr im Büro, weil es ist irgendwie einundzwanzig Uhr. Macht nichts. Man kann sich äh für die nächsten Tage ähm Anruferinnerungen einrichten
dann äh klingelt das Telefon zu der Zeit, die man vorher ausgewählt hat und man wird nochmal mit einer Ansage,
grob informiert darüber und,
kann da nochmal eine Taste drücken und wird verbunden mit dem Büro des Abgeordneten. Es ist auch kein Prozess, der dich sozusagen sofort ins kalte Wasser schubst. Es gibt auch auf der Webseite schön äh alle Anrufleitfaden,
mit dem was passieren wird, wo man können wir vielleicht durchgehen, äh mal zum ersten Mal gesagt bekommt, wenn da jemand dran geht, am Telefon, stell dich vor.
Wer du bist und von wo du bist. Und dass es dir um die anstehende Abstimmung zum Urheberrecht und Artikel dreizehn geht. Und dann,
erinnere sie auch daran, dass es im Mai eine Europawahl gibt. Verbind dieser zwei Themen und dann versuch einfach dem,
Politiker oder der Politikerin dieses Versprechen abzunehmen gegen
Upload-Filter äh zu stimmen und äh da einfach auf Punkt EU zu gehen. Und die Abgeordneten melden sich dann bei uns, wenn sie das unterschreiben wollen. Wir pflegen sie auf der Webseite ein.
Jetzt stelle ich mir natürlich vor, die Leute werden ja also wird da ein Fachgespräch stattfinden, wie ist so deine Erfahrung aus diesen Anrufen?
Nee, nee, in allen einen allermeisten Fällen nicht, weil die Leute, die da abheben
also man kann sich da schon äh hin und wieder mit den Leuten unterhalten, aber äh oft geht's denen nur drum, irgendwie so ein grundlegendes Gespür dafür zu bekommen. Europaabgeordnete haben
zwischen drei und sieben Angestellte und es gibt wahrscheinlich eine Person, die sich wirklich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
Und äh der Großteil der Leute arbeiten auch nicht am Polecy, sondern an anderen Dingen, die im Büro so anfallen. Deswegen ähm werden wir da jetzt nicht immer sofort in ein Fachgespräch gedrängt
ähm man kann auch einfach sagen, dass es äh meine Besorgnis ich äh konsumiere gerne YouTube, ich äh
bin selber vielleicht mit einem Kanal dort aktiv. Ich äh bin Techniker, ich bin äh Soziologe, keine Ahnung, was auch immer der eigene Hintergrund ist oder einfach nur ich bin äh ein potenzieller Wähler
und ich hab hier irgendwie Besorgnis, dass Sie hier etwas bestimmen, ähm, was massiv kritisiert wurde aus vielen Seiten und was gefährlich ist für meine Lebensrealit,
Also man muss jetzt nicht versuchen, die Leute zu überzeugen, sondern nur das eigene Besorgnis äh und die Bedenken äh kommunizieren.
Weil im Endeffekt die Politiker sind ja dafür da, sich selber ein Bild zu machen aufgrund von allen Input, den sie bekommen.
Äh die Stimme der Bevölkerung ist halt genau das, was bisher unterrepräsentiert war und deswegen ist die eigene Stimme jetzt hier auch äh sprichwörtlich so wichtig.
Muss ich davon ausgehen, dass die dass sich den vielleicht, dass ich die störe, ist das ein Problem.
Die sind dafür da, dass sie mit euch kommunizieren. Also das sind äh äh von Steuergeld, bezahlte Mitarbeiter von jeden einzelnen Menschen in Europa. Und ähm die äh,
sind auch äh in den allerbesten Fällen sehr freundlich, ja. Ähm die sind's oft nicht gewohnt, dass sie wirklich aus den Mitgliedsstaaten Anrufe bekommen von ihren eigenen Wählerinnen und Wählern. Deswegen ähm.
Hat man da eigentlich eher ein freudiges Empfangen.
Und ähm wenn sie in Straßburg sind, sind sie vielleicht mal eher ein bissel gestresster. Ähm, das wollte ich dazu sagen, es gibt ja in Brüssel und in Straßburg Büros der Abgeordne.
Unser Tool kümmert sich aber darum, ihr müsst nicht entscheiden, wo die gerade sind, sondern
wir verbinden euch immer automatisch mit dem Büro, ähm wo jetzt auch jemand abheben sollte, aber jetzt auch Dienszeiten sind,
Und in den meisten Fällen sind das äh ganz nette Gespräche
und wenn ihr da einfach sagt, so ich bin gegen Artikel dreizehn Uploadfilter und bitte äh versprechen sie, dass sie dagegen stimmen werden. Ähm dann ist das eigentlich schon ein,
dann dann hat man das Sole eigentlich schon erfüllt
Da werdende aber auch nette Gespräche da draus. Ja, also wenn man freundlich mit denen äh spricht, äh erfährt man doch teilweise immer wieder Sachen, ähm äh die Abgeordneten, die eher auf unserer Seite
sagen dann gleich, okay, melde dich bitte auch noch bei dem und Themen, weil äh die wollen ja selber auch irgendwie eine Mehrheit haben gegen Uploadfilter.
Ähm und äh die Abgeordneten, die freundlich sind, die kann man nur auch wirklich bitten, diesen Pletsch zu unterschreiben, dann äh werden die Anrufe auf die fokussiert, die noch übrig sind.
Also nichts, nichts zu befürchten. Du hast, was ist das Schlimmste, was ich zu zu erwarten hätte? Äh geht geht keiner dran.
Oder oder ich mache einen dummen Eindruck und die sagen äh äh sie haben, haben sie den Text gelesen und ich sage äh
Nein oder sagen sehen sie, ne? Also hier so Nancy Pelocy Style, ja? Äh
äh Kinderchen, dann äh verpisst euch mal, ne? So, lasst, lasst das mal den Papa machen, ne? Das äh das wäre das Schlimmste, was mir passieren kann und was was wäre das, hat das negative Konsequenzen für mich? Nein, eigentlich nicht, ne.
Nein.
Nein, also überhaupt nicht. Also wenn äh wenn ich da jetzt irgendwie bei Axel Forst anrufe, äh der wird sich nicht überzeugen lassen. Ähm äh da da muss man halt auch unterscheiden, Leute, die ähm.
Bezahlt werdende Meinung zu haben oder die Angst haben ihre Meinung zu ändern, die wird man nicht überzeugen.
Aber der Großteil der Abgeordneten ist noch irgendwo dazwischen.
Da ist so ein Gespräch wirklich ein großer Unterschied. Ähm und weil's so selten vorkommt, ist es auch so wahnsinnig effizient.
Es ist halt äh für die auch wirklich etwas okay gut, da da brodelt's nicht nur, da ist schon der Vulkan am Ausbrechen. Wenn die wirklich bei uns anrufen
Das ist für einen selber vielleicht so äh der große Arzt, wo ich auch ganz lange auf der Website herumscrolle, bevor ich mich traue, das zu tun.
Für die Gegenseite aber auch. Also äh die die sind.
Die haben auch Angst. Du meinst für die ist das genauso schlimm.
Ja genau.
Und ähm also in, äh, wenn, wenn man da jetzt wirklich auf so einen Hardcore-Menschen trifft, sie haben den Text doch nicht gelesen.
Dann ist das im Zweifelsfall nur, weil ja auch Angst.
YouTube-Videos.
Ja genau, also ihr könnt denen irgendwie das Lehmann Video schicken. Ähm wir verlinken dann nochmal YouTube-Videos, wo Rechtsanwälte sich den Text durchlesen
und äh das nochmal bestärken aufgrund des des des letzten Statements. Ich äh kann nicht zu viel verraten, aber wir werden auch nochmal sehr.
Schwergewichte für Sprecher,
organisieren. Jetzt auf Basis des finalen Textes, die sich auch nochmal äußern, die ja auch noch erwähnen können, wo sie einfach keine
keine argumentative Möglichkeit mehr haben zu sagen, sie haben den Text nicht gelesen. Also die Fakten, die sollten klar sein. Es ist eine politische Entscheidung. Ähm.
Was was einem passieren kann. Leider ist das,
das nicht abgehoben wird, das ist vor allem eben, wenn's zu früh oder zu spät ist, also vor acht oder nach ähm achtzehn Uhr oder zur Mittagszeit zwischen zwölf und dreizehn Uhr,
ist aber auch pro Land unterschiedlich, das mit Mittagspause und Ciesta ist ja nicht überall einheitlich
und unser Tool versucht euch auch da es so einfach wie möglich zu machen und ihr könnt auch immer über die Website gehen und dort anrufen wenn der Dir Call Erinnerung nicht funktioniert. Man kann das auch alles über die.
Ändern und natürlich auch irgendwie ähm äh Daten beausduften und löschen und so das ganze Ding ist GTBA konform.
Nichts anderes hätte ich bei euch erwartet. Ähm,
du hast jetzt gesagt, äh vierundfünfzig Abgeordnete zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zwei Tage nach Launch, haben da schon sich diesen Pletsch geleistet. Was äh ist das, ist das ein Erfolg? Ist das keiner? Ist das, viel ist das wenig.
Das ist ein Erfolg. Also ähm wir ähm haben mit weitaus weniger am Anfang gerechnet.
Wenn wir diese Zuwachsrate haben, dann ist das schon gut und vor allem das Ding beginnt ja jetzt erst, sich wirklich an die Abgeordneten zu wenden
und wir brauchen insgesamt dreihundertsechsundsiebzig für 'ne einfache Mehrheit im Plenum
das heißt da ist noch Luft und da ist es jetzt halt einfach wichtig.
Diese Zahl nach oben zu bringen. Es wird dann auch ähm zur Berichterstattung geben, also es wird dann für die Organisationen in Deutschland
wie bei der Wahlberichterstattung in den USA, wo man sieht, wo schon Abgeordnete sind, wo noch welche fehlen, ja, um's einfach auch nachvollziehbar zu machen. Ja, also wir erzielen jetzt hier auch eine Geschichte, die Geschichte der Abstimmung beginnt schon jetzt. Wir organisieren uns jetzt schon diese Mehrheit
und äh versuchen so halt wirklich auf die.
Äh Abgeordneten zuzugehen und ähm einfach der Gegenseite auch die Luft wegzunehmen, weil die Gegenseite operiert im Schatten
versucht jetzt ähm über über Lobbygespräche mit den Leuten ähm.
Zu überzeugen oder auch wirklich aktiv Druck auszuüben. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja auch die Verlagsseite. Ähm äh gerade eben die FAZ da habe ich gehört, ist hier sehr aktiv und da wird auch schon mal so gesagt, na ja, wollen sie noch vorkommen im Wahlkampf oder nicht?
Dann wissen sie ja, wie sie abzustimmen haben. Ähm also wir wir müssen jetzt hier auch irgendwie Gegenpol liefern für die Abgeordneten, dass die
das Richtige tun und und sich eben nicht einschüchtern lassen
und auch wenn wenn dann zum Beispiel auch dieses Argument kommt ja aber Google muss zahlen ja Google sind diejenigen die am ehesten profitieren von dieser Lösung. Die haben schon Uploadfilter
die können sich die Lizenzen äh leisten. Ähm ich glaube da war auch heute oder gestern ein Artikel, dass der Bundesdatenschutz beauf
davor warnen. Das was du immer gesagt hast, Linos, wenn wenn wir Uploadfilter haben, dann kommen die von Google, ähm dann müssen Redit und Vimeo alle ihre Daten bei Google abliefern, um sie dort durch den Fil.
Halte ich auch tatsächlich für ähm also.
Ich halte das für das wichtigste Argument. Das wichtigste Argument aus aus welchem Grunde ähm.
Weil das etwas ist, was diese EU-Parlamentarier alle noch verstehen, ja? Ähm wenn du.
Also das Argument hier Zensurfilter und so weiter, das ist auch richtig, ja? Aber es ist bei weitem abgenutzter, ja. Ähm als was jetzt über die.
Ne, weil es einfach über die Jahre immer eine, ja, aber das Urheberrecht und und die armen Künstler und ne und so weiter.
Das ist genauso abgenutzt, das könnt ihr alles nicht mehr hören, da werden die nicht mehr da wacht keiner mehr für auf, ja? Das ist jetzt irgendwie so ein, wenn du jetzt sagst
Ja, da hat einer angerufen. Aha, was wollt ihr denn? Ja, der wollte sich gegen die Copyright äh Dingens äh wenden. Aha, mit welchem Argument ja Zensur und Freiheit im Internet so, ja, kennen wir.
So dass Zensurenfreiheit im Internet ist inzwischen halt äh diese diese Rege, diese diese Sprache, die es im Prinzip bei den,
Befürwortern der Copyright Reform vollständig leer, ja? Dass das bedeutet für die nichts mehr, ne? Weil sie sagen, komm, das ist äh das kennen wir, wir kennen aber auch hier die andere Seite, nämlich.
Krokodils Tränen bei den Verlagen und wir müssen hier mal eben.
Diesen diese Millionenwirtschaft der Freiheit äh und der Information und der Kultur retten vor dem bösen Google, ja? Wenn du da aber anrufst und sagst, pass mal auf, das, was ihr da vorhabt, ne.
Das ist die, das sichert endgültig die Vormachtstellung von Google. Euer Feind.
In jeder, in jeder Perspektive wirtschaftspolitisch ähm im Bereich ähm.
Datenschutz und so weiter steuern. Es ist relativ klar.
Wenn du da in auf Europaebene sitzt und versuchst für Europa ähm Politik zu machen, dann ist Google, das sind die Bösen
Das ist ganz klar. Google und Facebook sind der Feind. Die zahlen keine Steuern, die die brechen, die halten sich nicht an die Gesetze, die ruinieren ganze Wirtschaftszweige. Das ist einfach.
Ganz klar erklärte Feind. Und wenn du da sagst, pass mal auf und das ist ja so, es ist ja auch inhaltlich korrekt. Das, was ihr da vorhabt, das wird einfach nur deren Vormachtstellung stärken, nichts anderes. Niemand wird ähm.
Äh sagen können, äh ach so ja hier, wir sind äh keine Ahnung, ein kleines Start-up, was äh versucht, sich mit denen anzulegen. Äh wir bauen jetzt mal eben noch einen Upload-Filter, ja.
Und äh und dann werden wir, werden wir äh wird es uns gelingen.
Mit denen zu konkurrieren und dann sind wir das nächste europäische Google oder sowas, ja
das wird einfach nicht passieren. Du wirst als europäisches Startup vor der in der Situation sein, zu sagen, Scheiße, um überhaupt hier in die, in unserem schönen Europa operieren zu können, brauchen wir Uploadfilter.
Was was will Google dafür haben, ja? Und dann wird Google, nämlich das wird der nächste Gag sein.
Da werden Google und Facebook nämlich sagen, ach ja, weil wir äh weil wir so freundlich sind, liebe Start-ups bieten wir euch diese Upload-Filter kostenlos an, ja? Und dann werden die gefragt werden, warum bietet ihr den Kostenlos an und werden die sagen, ja, um um euch den Eintritt in diesen Markt zu ermöglichen, damit wir hier Konkurrenz haben können während
letztendlich, dass es einfach nur heiß.
Alles was auf dieser Plattform passiert, wird den Nummer frei hausgeliefert, die haben da überhaupt keinen Grund mehr, mit denen zu Konko. Also die haben gar keinen Grund mehr mit der Konkurrenzplattform zu konkurrieren, weil sie die Inhalte ja eh bekommen. Und alles, was die haben wollen, sind Daten.
Also ich ich mir ist völlig unklar wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, denen diese.
Machtmöglichkeit zu zu bieten und zu geben, ja? Die werden halt diese Inhalte frei Haus geliefert bekommen. Das haben wir ähm.
Als CC oder ich saß hier eh schon die ganze Zeit im Podcast, wir haben das als CC irgendwann im äh September letzten Jahres auch nochmal gesagt und ich.
Hocherfreut, dass der neue Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte.
Ulrich Kälber, das der ist ja Informatiker, dass der das auch versteht und das auch so vertritt, das ist doch äh ist doch schön. Ist doch äh ähm wir haben ja einen.
Einen Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten oder eine Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte mit Kompetenz und ähm.
Äußerungsfreudigkeit, lange Zeit vermisst. Jetzt haben wir wieder jemanden. Das ist doch toll.
Also ich ich sehe es genauso wie du und ich finde es schön, dass diese Argumente jetzt auch wirklich ankommen. Also ähm es mangelt, also man kann je nicht sagen, ihr habt den Text nicht gelesen
das ist ein Bullshit-Argument.
Bringt man nur, wenn man sich nicht mit der Kritik an diesem Text auseinandersetzen will und ähm ja, ich glaube, du bist da sehr überzeugend, also ähm Dinos, bist du deine Abgeordneten anrufen.
Ja ich werde da anrufen, aber ich ich habe genau, ich habe nämlich tatsächlich noch eine Frage. Ich hab's bisher.
Noch nicht gemacht, weil ich viel zu tun hatte. Ähm ich habe aber vor allem eine ähm.
Frage, wenn man auf die Seite kommt, wird da scheinbar ähm,
zufällig einfach eine Person ausgewählt. Und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass es eine Person ist, die für mich auf dem Wahlzettel stehen wird. Das heißt, ich habe da wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel Drohpotential, oder?
Ähm ja das Problem ist, dass äh dass äh Wahlrecht fürs Europaparlament nicht harmonisiert ist, sondern bei den einzelnen Mitgliedsstaaten ist. Und ähm wir bestimmen anhand der Browser-Sprache, welche Übersetzung du angezeigt bekommst und der
welches Land du bist, du kannst das Land aber ändern. Und im Moment ist es noch so, dass du da eben immer einen zufälligen Abgeordneten ausgewählt bekommst aus deinem Land
die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit hat, dass er noch überzeugt werden kann. Also da ist auch eine Logik dahinter
wenn du mit einem anderen sprechen willst, musst du im Moment halt die
Seite neu laden. Ähm es gibt nun nicht die Möglichkeit, die explizit da auszuwählen. Ähm das ist aber was, wo ich mir gut vorstellen kann, dass wir das noch äh im Nachhinein programmieren.
Ähm ist ja also ist ja vielleicht auch gar nicht so verkehrt ähm so etwas dadurch lenken zu lassen. Ne, ihr wisst ja, im Zweifelsfall, wer hat schon Anrufe, wie ist die Lage, insofern ist er nicht verkehrt, mich dahin zu lenken, wo ich.
Anrufen, wo es am sinnvollsten ist, dass dass da jetzt angerufen wird. Ähm,
ich war nur erst überrascht, insofern freue ich mich, dass so mal erklärt.
Also es soll wirklich äh so einfach der Prozess wie möglich sein, dass da eigentlich nur auf die Seite gehst, deine Nummer angibst, du kriegst einen Anruf von Thomand Live, du kriegst nochmal die letzten Infos, die siehst du auch auf der Webseite und dann.
So eine Taste und bist verbunden und das eben wirklich auch wiederkehrend, sodass du eigentlich nichts anderes tun musst als deine eigenen Argumente in deiner eigenen Stimme formulieren und dass wenn das genügend Leute machen, habe ich.
Noch Hoffnung, dass wir das gewinnen können. Es ist zumindest so die beste Art, die mir eingefallen ist und die, die unserem ganzen Team eingefallen ist, wie wir das Ding noch drehen könnten.
Und ja, in einem Monat wissen wir, ob's gereicht hat.
Alles klar, jetzt würde ich äh das Telefonat, das Telefonat, den Podcast damit, das Telefonat
Äh damit beenden wir viel Erfolg zu wünschen, aber äh viel wichtiger ist eigentlich natürlich euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zu bitten, da anzurufen und das mal zu nutzen. Ähm.
Argumente gibt's genug. Meine persönliche Schätzung ist, dass dieses ähm.
Facebook, Google macht Stärken, Argument, eines ist, was vielleicht am am ersten verfängt, weil es ähm.
In deren Perspektive ein paradoxes Argument ist.
Weil sie nicht verstanden haben, dass ihre Perspektive paradox ist. Und ähm das ist natürlich im Zweifelsfall oder hoffentlich etwas, was.
Vielleicht auch ein ein Gespräch ähm das Gespräch in eine Richtung lenkt, wo ihr relativ.
Einfach ähm.
Gewinnen könnt im Sinne von ähm Dinge anbringen könnt, die einleuchtend kommunizierbar sind und die dann vielleicht auch verstanden werden und vielleicht sogar.
Ähm da zu einem Umdenken führen.
Zumindest wäre das etwas, wo mir ist das diese Argumentation eine, die ich auch mit Platitüden nicht entkraft entkräftet sehe, äh sehe, ne? Wenn du sagst, hier Zensurmaschine sind, nein.
Im Text steht nicht Uploadfilter, dann musste Sascha Lobo zitieren
Ja, das ist auch sehr schön, Sascha Lore, Spiegel, Online letzte Woche. Äh da steht zwar nicht Uploadfilter drin, aber es ist ungefähr so, wie vorzuschreiben, dass man von Frankfurt nach New York in acht Stunden kommen muss. Die einzige Möglichkeit
ist im normalen Flugzeug, ja? Und äh das fand ich äh fand ich äh auch sehr, sehr schöne Vergleiche bei Sascha Lobe sowieso. Regelmäßig.
Perfekt. Gut verlinken wir doch. Ähm ist wunderbar. Dann äh haben wir, glaube ich, noch Termine.
Ein Termin, dass ich habe den auch nur drin, weil ich mal zeigen wollte, du hast mich ja hier ein bisschen geschämt, dass ich noch nicht angerufen habe. Ähm.
Ich gehe aber so weit, ja. Ich bin am sechsten März, ich weiß aber nicht, ob das dann gesendet wird oder nicht bei Rocket Beans.
Was ist das?
Äh das ist ähm ein YouTube-Kanal, der wenn ich das richtig sehe ähm live streamt.
Also ähm Rocket Rocket Beans Punkt TV ist eine Hamburger ähm YouTube-Livestreamer, ja? Die da irgendwie ähm ein vierundzwanzig sieben.
Streamen haben und da eben unterschiedliche Sendungsformate sich irgendwie mit ne, wir was du so machst, ne? Irgendwelche Games, äh politische Themen und so weiter in verschiedenen.
Formen gemischt und im Prinzip ein YouTube Fernsehsender. Ähm man könnte sagen.
Ein ein Internet-Start-Up aus Hamburg, so lange gibt's hier noch nicht, gibt's glaube ich erst ein paar Jahre. Man könnte sagen, ein Internet-Start-up aus Hamburg, ja, das äh relativ klar von diesem,
Thema Upload-Filter äh betroffen ist.
Und man könnte sagen, deswegen erwähne ich's hier. Da sieht man mal, dass auch Linus sich jetzt hier, ne, die Ärmel hochkrempelt und dahin geht.
Ob's weh tut. Ähm nein, äh da da äh äh in die äh ins YouTube. Ich gehe sogar ins YouTube.
Ja, ich glaube, dass Youtuber hier sowieso die, die haben sich schon sehr viele Medaillen verdient.
Bei diesem Thema, ähm dass sie darauf hinweisen und ich hoffe auch, dass die weiter aktiv bleiben. Äh ich habe auch noch einen Termin äh und zwar äh das Elevat-Festival.
Ähm das ist jetzt nämlich ähm diese Woche, also es beginnt heute um siebenundzwanzigsten und äh geht noch bis zum,
März in Graz, äh das ist auch äh ein wiederkehrendes Event. Und eine der spanischsten Netzpolitischen Konferenzen in Österreich. Ähm
und dieses Jahr gibt's auch einen Stargast und zwar Pemela Anderson. Ähm.
Die äh ja sehr sehr kluges Zeug sagte in letzter Zeit. Also ich finde das äh toll irgendwie, dass sie da ähm.
In einigen Stellen aktiv wird äh und äh ja ich bin gespannt darauf, was sie, was sie dort in ihrer Rede sagen wird.
Ja
Wunderbar, ich habe gerade nochmal geschaut, also diese Rocket Beans Sache ist eine Aufzeichnung, deswegen weiß ich nicht, wann es genau äh gesendet wird.
Ah ja ähm gut, wunderbar. Ähm ja, wer in Graz ist, kann vorbeikommen, auch am Donnerstag äh streite ich mit der EU-Kommission über Fake-News und ähm.
Mit der EU kommen ein bisschen, weißt du, wer kommt oder ist das für derjenige, ist das ein Blo.
Ein ein Vertreter für die Kommission von Österreich, das heißt, das wir
ähm ja ähm ein Verwaltungsbeamter der Marketing macht höchstwahrscheinlich, aber ich bin trotzdem gespannt auf die Diskussion.
Gerade Fake News, da habe ich ein paar Beispiele aus der jüngeren Geschichte, ähm die das veranschaulichen, da glaube ich, werden wir eine spannende Debatte haben.
Wunderbar, Thomas, vielen vielen Dank und liebe Hörerinnen, liebe Hörer, greift's zu dem Telefon, lasst euch äh verbinden mit den Büros der Abgeordneten. Führt da mal ein Gespräch.
Tut gar nicht so weh. Ich muss, ich werde dieses Pflaster auch gleich abreißen. Ich habe ja jetzt schon das Headset auf und kann hier gleich auf den Knopf drücken.
Und dann werde ich denen mal kurz meine Meinung geigen. So, damit sind wir am Ende und an diesem Ende danke ich noch kurz dem Michael und die nächste Folge Logbuch wird gar nicht so lange.
Auf sich warten lassen.
Ciao ciao, bis bald.
Ciao ciao.